biontech
vaccine for distribution across the
united kingdom
after months of clinical trials
involving thousands of people
to ensure that the vaccine meets the
strictest
internationally recognized standards of
safety quality
and effectiveness thanks to the
fantastic work of
kate bingham and the vaccines task force
we've purchased
more than 350 million doses of seven
different vaccine candidates and the uk
was the first country in the world
to pre-order supplies of this pfizer
vaccine
securing 40 million doses through our
winter plan the nhs has been preparing
for the biggest program
of mass vaccination in the history of
the uk and that's going to begin
next week and in line with the advice of
the independent
joint committee on vaccination and
immunization
the first phase will include care home
residents
health and care staff the elderly and
those who are
clinically extremely vulnerable but
there are immense
logistical challenges the virus has got
to be stored
at minus 70 degrees each person needs
two injections
three weeks apart so it will inevitably
take
some months before all the most
vulnerable
are protected long cold months so
it's all the more vital that as we
celebrate this scientific achievement
we're not
carried away with over optimism
or fall into the naive belief that the
struggle is
over it's not we've got to stick to our
winter plan
a comprehensive program to suppress the
virus protect the nhs
and the vulnerable keep education and
the economy going
and use treatments testing and vaccines
to enable us to return to much closer to
normal
by the spring today in england we've
ended national restrictions
opening up significant parts of the
economy in doing so
but also replacing them with tough tears
to keep
this virus down and i know that those
tears will mean continued
uh hardship for for many and it's gonna
continue to be
tough for some sectors but until the
vaccine
is deployed our plan does rely
on all of us continuing to make
sacrifices to protect
those we love so please please continue
to follow
the rules where you live remember hands
face
space and if you live in a tier
3 area where community
testing will be made available please
take part in that community testing
together these steps are for now
the surest way to protect yourselves and
those you love and by reducing the
transmission of the virus
help de-escalate your area
to a lower level of restrictions as as
vaccines and testing
as i say take an ever larger share of
the burden
as we do all this we're no longer
resting on the mere
hope that we can return to normal
next year in the spring but rather the
sure
and certain knowledge that we will
succeed and
together reclaim our lives and all the
things about our lives
that we love so i want to thank the
scientists and all those
around the world who've taken part uh in
the trials and got us to this stage
and i want to hand over now to simon
stevens of the nhs
uh thank you and uh good afternoon
obviously as the prime minister
says today is a news uh
bringing great optimism we have a
vaccine that has been independently
shown to be
both safe and effective but i suspect
that what people
want are practical answers to three
questions
who will be first in line when will the
vaccines be available
and how will we get it to you from the
nhs
so taking those three questions in turn
first of all
in terms of who will be first in line as
the prime minister says
the independent medical experts the
joint committee on vaccination and
immunization
have clearly recommended that the nhs
should make sure
that the first people to be offered the
vaccine are those at
highest risk together with the people
who look after them
in practice what that means is starting
with the
over 80s who are at much higher risk of
severe outcomes from coronavirus as well
as people in care homes
together with some of the frontline
health and social care staff who are
looking after them
and then as more vaccine becomes
available we will be
in the new year extending that to many
more people
across the country in line with the jcvi
recommendations so that in turn helps
answer the question
when in that although we are the first
health service
in the world to be able to get
vaccinating
supplies from the manufacturer are
phased
so the initial tranche in december is
going to enable us to get started but
the bulk of this vaccination program
either through this vaccine or hopefully
others as well that will join it
will take place in the period january
through to
march or april for the at-risk
population
the majority of the early vaccinations
will as i say be for the over 80s and
for
care home residents and since you need
two jabs with an initial injection and
then a booster
typically around 21 days apart that
means that
we've got to reserve the second dose for
the people who are getting the first
dose in december
to make sure that that second dose is
available for them
and it also means that the people who
are getting the first dose
in december will not have the full
protection from the vaccine
until they get the second dose in
january which
emphasizes the point that we need to
continue to be extremely careful
during december and into january and
then as vaccination expands to
the wider population so that's who
and that's when in terms of how
the vaccine that has been approved for
the nhs to deploy
today the fisa beyond tech vaccine has
been
independently shown to be medically safe
but it is
logistically complicated we have to move
it around the country
in a carefully controlled way initially
at minus 70 degrees centigrade or
thereabouts
and then there are a limited number of
further movements that we are
allowed by the regulator to make it also
comes in packs of 975 people's doses
so you can't at this point just
distribute it to
every individual gp surgery or pharmacy
as we normally would for many of the
other vaccines available
on the nhs so
the phasing of delivery the way we will
do it
is that next week around 50 hospital
hubs
across england will start offering the
vaccine
to the over 80s and to care home
staff and others identified by the jcvi
typically they may be people who were
already down to come into hospital next
week for an outpatient appointment
so if you're going to be one of those
people next week or in the
weeks that follow the hospital will get
in touch with you
you don't need to do anything about it
yourself
that will then be followed in the
subsequent weeks
with gp practices coming together in
each area
to operate local vaccination centers
and that will grow to over a thousand
places
right across england where gps will be
in touch with their at-risk patients
inviting people to come forward for
vaccination
we've had an excellent response from gps
across the nhs wanting to participate in
this program
and as the extra vaccine comes available
we'll be able to turn on more of those
gp led clinics
and then if the mhra the independent
regulator as we expect they will give
approval for
a safe way of splitting these packs of
975 doses
then the good news is that we will be
able to start
distributing those two care homes
and then as even more vaccine becomes
available
finally we will be able to switch on
large vaccination centers across the
country
and indeed invite local community
pharmacists
probably at the beginning of january to
begin to offer vaccination
as well so in a nutshell
this is going to be a phased program we
the nhs
your gp or your hospital the nhs will
contact you
if you are ready to be offered the
vaccination
and today of course is a day of great
optimism but for all the reasons i've
said i think it needs to be tempered
with
realism around phasing the nhs has got a
fantastic track record
around vaccine delivery but this is the
first time in the world
that these particularly complicated
logistics are being put into practice
and finally i should of course conclude
i think with a big thank you to
not only the scientists and the
researchers who
have managed to produce this vaccine but
to all of my fellow staff across the
health service the
nurses and doctors and the therapists
and the paramedics
who are all going to now mobilize for
what is the biggest vaccination campaign
in our history thank you thank you very
much simon uh
john with anything to add thanks prime
minister
yes i'd like to add a few um science
reflections if i may
and and begin with the fact to tell you
quite openly and i don't mind
telling you um i'm not saying it for
effect the office will tell you it's
true
that i was quite emotional this morning
when i heard
june reign seminar muhammad and wei shen
lim
lay out how they got very meticulously
to their conclusions about the fisa
vaccine
and what a momentous you know journey
and international effort it has been
um discovery by two scientists who
originally
um lived in turkey development by a
german biotech company
involvement of a massive u.s
pharmaceutical giant
and then involvement of our own uk mhra
to bring home the goods in terms of the
uk what a fantastic
journey and i gave you the train analogy
many weeks ago now
the train has now slowed down safely it
has now stopped in the station
and the doors have opened that was the
authorization
by the mhra what we need now is for
people to get on that train
and travel safely to their destinations
those destinations are all over the uk
this train is going to stop several
times on the way
it's going to have to reach all parts of
the uk
there will be trains that come behind it
and that is all going to take time
so everyone needs to be delighted with
the news today
but equally patient and realistic
about how this rolls out over the next
few months
and now some serious science points
number one we have one authorized
vaccine but we need more we're very
hopeful
we will get some more but it is still
possible that some of the ones in
development
will fall by the wayside and you have to
be prepared for that
we then need assured supply and that is
a big
and difficult ask for manufacturers and
it won't all come at once
and it may stop and start a bit at times
we just have to manage that as best we
can
as it happens number three
we need people to take it this vaccine
isn't going to help you if you don't
take it
and you will need two doses of this
vaccine and most of the others
to have full protection
watching others take it and hoping that
this will then protect you
isn't going to work necessarily we don't
know if this vaccine will prevent
transmission
or any of them we have to wait for the
science to tell us
if it will prevent transmission though
we are
very hopeful on that point we also have
to be patient
to see the real live effects on
transmission
and hospitalizations and deaths and
until we see that
as scientists we can't then scope
what the likely impact is going to be
on bringing this pandemic to an early
end
and rollout won't be instant already on
the jcvi
phase one list we have around about
30 million people who are going to be
targeted at some point
and even if you gave me 60 million
vaccines here in this corner now
in a freezer of course but if you gave
me the 60 million
um i couldn't you know no no system in
the world
could distribute those really really
quickly in a matter of a few days
so we have to be realistic about how
long this is going to take it's going to
take months not weeks
and for now the other measures
the tear measures the social distancing
have to stay in place if we relax too
soon
if we just kind of go are the vaccines
here let's abandon caution
all you're going to do is create a tidal
wave of infections
and this vaccine's then got to work in a
headwind
to get back ahead of the game and that
will make it harder
and then the final point is look you
know everyone wants
social distancing to come to an end
we're fed up with it
nobody wants lockdowns and to see the
damage they do
but if you want that dream to come true
as quickly as it can come true
then you have to take the vaccine when
it's offered to you
low uptake will almost certainly make
restrictions last
longer and finally please stick to the
guidance
until we say it is safe to stop thank
you
thanks very much let's go to questions
from the public first
dylan from thousands of year 13 students
like myself
across the country have been held in
suspense over the last few months
over at a levels when does the
government intend to provide certainty
as to what is being planned for next
summer right dylan thank you very much
and
uh first of all i i want to thank uh
everybody who's
uh been in school and the efforts that
schools teachers
pupils have gone to to uh keep our
schools going that's been one of the
prime objectives of
the way we've bought the pandemic here
in uh in this country to to make sure
kids are
are in school uh dylan uh we're going to
be sending out some more tomorrow
about uh about exams but let me just say
that we want
uh exams to to go ahead we think they're
very
uh very important but we'll also be
setting out some ways which we're gonna
help uh uh pupils to to do them
uh next time given the exceptional
circumstances that uh
the country finds itself in and given
that uh you know so many
uh pupils have had uh their education
disrupted
by the pandemic so we'll be sending out
a lot more about that
uh tomorrow let's go to catherine
uh from from queenibr
i'm sorry catherine asks which
hospitality tear restrictions
remain in place over the uh christmas
relaxation
uh will families be able to socialize in
pubs and restaurants
or just in their in their houses and
i'm sorry to say um uh catherine that
we've got to stick with the
uh the the guidance that we've uh
we've set out the tiering system
throughout the the christmas period
uh as the simon was was was just saying
and jonathan as well uh it would be a
really fatal mistake now
uh to uh to respond to this good news
uh by letting the virus uh you know
run riot again letting it get out of
control by
too much uh transmission over
over christmas and so that's why we've
got to stick uh very tightly to the
tearing
that we've uh we've set out um let's go
to questions from the
from the media fergus walsh bbc
prime minister now we have a vaccine how
important is this moment
uh well fergus this is a a huge moment
and
uh as as jvt was jonathan
van tan was just saying it's also a very
moving thing
and i'm really lost in admiration for
and the ability of scientists to to
solve human problems in the way that uh
they can and this is not easy i mean
don't bear in mind we've got a we've got
a
a vaccine now for kobe that really
really
works there's no question that it uh
that it works but we haven't got a
vaccine for
uh for sars or for mers
for hiv you know there's a huge huge
fantastic effort
has gone into this and um when you
consider
the damage that as i was saying earlier
the damage that
this virus has done to uh human life
across the
uh the planet the economic damage the
social damage to say nothing of the
the cost in in life and and suffering it
is a fantastic moment
but you know to repeat the key message
the worst thing now
would be to think that this is the
moment when we can
relax our guard and uh think that it's
game over
in the fight against kobe this is not uh
this is not the end
uh we have to fight on and we have to
continue with the
uh the tough measures that we've uh that
we've we've announced today
thanks very much uh fergus let's go to
uh to emily morgan
of itv hello thank you a question
to you prime minister uh your scientists
have said that
care home residents should be the first
people to
get this uh vaccine are you confirming
then that
they won't be and if uh not
aren't you failing to protect our most
vulnerable and if i may a question to
you simon stevens what are you doing
right now
to address this logistical challenge to
get the vaccine to care homes
sooner rather than later well i i think
i'll i'll ask simon to to correct me if
i've got this wrong but
you're quite right but the issue is we
of course we want to get it
into care homes to protect the the most
vulnerable as fast as we
uh possibly can uh the the joint
committee on vaccination and
immunization has rightly said that care
home residents
must be a priority uh the difficulty
is in uh distributing the uh the cases
to
uh care homes each case has 975
vaccines in it and obviously you want to
avoid
wastage and the difficulty is that the
mhra has not yet
uh authorized the people who would be uh
transporting uh the vaccine to the to
the care homes
to be able to effect the division uh
themselves i know it sounds
uh complicated uh emily that's because
this
this vaccine and and jv team also
jonathan may want to come back on this
this vaccine is
uh it's it's it needs to be kept uh
deep frozen as you know minus uh 75
there is a risk that if it is allowed to
to degenerate by being
improperly handled it simply won't work
so the rules around the transport of
this
vaccine are extremely important and to
get your point about
um speeding this up and making sure we
get it into care homes
uh as soon as possible uh we're
expecting to hear
more soon from the mhra about how that
can happen but
i think it'd be fair to say that uh
there are we certainly want to be
uh putting it into uh the the groups
that
uh simon uh talked about just now care
home residents
uh care workers uh nhs and above all
uh above all uh those above 80
who are the most vulnerable our
objective must be
to use the vaccine stocks that we have
to protect those who are most likely
not just to fall ill uh but to succumb
uh to the disease that's the
that's the what what the jcbi has
decided i think
uh quite rightly but uh jonathan and
simon
if i may come in prime minister and say
emily i think
you're your remarks about failure
are extremely unfair when one considers
that a new virus emerged less than 12
months ago
and we already have our first vaccine
and professor stevens has been very
clear that as soon as it is legally
and technically possible to get the
vaccine into care homes
um we will do so but you know that this
is
a complex product with a very fragile
cold chain it's not a yogurt that can be
taken out of the fridge
and put back in multiple times it's
really tricky to handle
and so i think you know we'll get there
as fast as we can is the answer
and we are trying extremely hard
sorry well no no i think you've both
said it absolutely accurately i mean we
are raring to go in the nhs we want to
be able to vaccinate people in care
homes for covid just as we vaccinate
care home residents for many other
things including winter flu
just as soon as we have the regulatory
sign off that we can
do that we can get the jabs to the care
homes so that the gps and the nurses can
then
arrive and give those care home
residents that took over vaccination we
will do that and we
at this point with a fair wind fully
expect that that will be in the
first tranche of uh priorities for
vaccination
uh during uh this month thanks very much
thanks emily let's go to beth rubio news
thank you prime minister we've got two
big events today celebrations about the
vaccine but also unhappiness
about the tier system you've told mps
that current restrictions will expire
on february the 3rd but given that you
also said in your cavity when to plan
that january and february are
traditionally the hardest months for the
nhs the depths of winter
when our hospital wards are under the
greatest pressure
should we all still prepare for
restrictions to run
through to april and have i made to
professor van tan
one in five britons have said in a
just-released yougov poll they're not
confident about this vaccine
how worried are you that people won't
take it
and given that you just said we don't
know if it reduces transmission
what percentage of the population would
need to take it
uh for it to be effective in us for to
be able to lift
restrictions thank you first of all just
on the
on the tearing and yes of course you
know i totally
accept that uh that they're tough these
tears are obviously
a huge amount of the economy is is
opened up but the
the restrictions uh do remain tough
particularly
in tier three on hospitality and we
deeply deeply
regret that we're doing everything we
can to to help but
you know the the way forward is not just
the steady rollout of the vaccine that
we and several vaccines we hope
that we've been describing over the next
few weeks and months
but also uh using uh
observation of the the tiering plus
community
testing uh as as we have in as they have
in
liverpool with great success 284 000
people in liverpool
uh took part in in community mass
testing
and so local leaders uh mps
everyone can get together to do those uh
community tests
and drive the uh and isolate the
positives
uh and uh help the negatives uh
to to do things differently and that way
drive the incidents down
and and get the virus under keep the
virus under control and come
down the tears uh we hope we hope
uh before uh easter as well so that's
the the tool that we see
uh working in addition uh to the vaccine
so beth thanks for the questions um
on a vaccine that reduces transmission
that is always the final big win if you
can get a vaccine that does that
because we can't be sure of that yet and
we'll have to wait
and see if that is the case with this
vaccine
and others to follow i'm quite
optimistic but far from certain
and because we can't say to what extent
the percentage of transmission
that is taken out by the vaccine because
it's not binary it's not kind of
it either does or it doesn't it's a
percentage that it will take out
until we know that and the scientists
can model that
we won't be able to say the kind of
total population vaccine uptake the
magic number you're after and
understand why you're after it but we
can't give it to you yet
um but i don't want to take away from
the the fact that the
not immediate but quite in the
foreground
and almost as big win is
stopping people going into hospital with
covid19
stopping them dying in hospital from
covid19
and removing that fear that they're
going to
have to run that risk and if we can do
that that's
much closer in in the terms of time to
the future
when we'll know those kind of answers
and we already know
from the preliminary data from
astrazeneca
as in their press releases that they had
no hospital
missions at all in the group that
received
the vaccine so you know those kind of
things are very encouraging
and if we can get the hospital burden
under control
then at that point and when we're
confident it's under control
we can start to think about what the
other options are
around the edges of getting this country
back to normal which we all want so much
so just kind of stay with us thank you
thank you
thank you let's jump in quickly promise
just to be clear do you expect to roll
over the tier system on february the 3rd
well we will we will judge the situation
uh
uh as as i told the house yesterday
repeated today
uh on the on the basis of the of the
data uh but uh
i think for the time being beth you've
got to take it the tiering
is going to be a very very important
part of
our uh our campaign against coronavirus
and it's it's
it's i think it's very it's absolutely
vital that people continue
to stick to the guidance and uh and
follow the rules
that is completely crucial mesa
hall of the express uh thank you prime
minister
um if i could ask the medical experts
first of all
as the vaccine is rolled out and we
progress through the priority list
at what stage would you feel it be right
to lift the majority of
the restrictions is it a matter of
inoculating people in the 70s 80s
who are most at risk or would you want
to see a much greater proportion of
population
vaccinated uh and prime minister um
this vaccine has been approved in the uk
faster than in eu
countries is that because we've left the
eu
should we see this is our first brexit
bonus our first big brexit bonus
and um on the subject of brexit the eu
is saying that
there's now less than 72 hours left to
cut a deal
how confident are you that we can get a
deal in that time
so maybe on the first question i'm sure
jvc wants to come in as well
the goal of the vaccination program just
like in the coronavirus just like for
anything else is
firstly to protect vulnerable
individuals and so the list that uh
given unfortunately coronavirus strikes
very unequally in terms of its impact
and you are at far greater risk if
you're over 80 than if you're
in your 30s and so forth that's why it's
a graduated list of the most vulnerable
people
that will help protect them and then the
second goal
is preventing people spreading it
unknowingly
to others and as jvt said we don't at
this point
know whether this vaccine will have that
effect
but that's obviously one of the great
benefits that you get from
the winter flu bab jab it's the benefit
you get from the measle mumps and
rubella
jab so there is a good reason for
thinking that that might be the case but
we don't
for definitively know that that's the
case as we sit here today
so most of all i would add to that is to
say that the jcvi
priority list phase one which takes us
down to
people 50 years of age and over
and obviously under the age of 15
under the age of 50
if you're in an at-risk group
taken together those groups it's not an
accident
that they take out with a very effective
vaccine and very high uptake
99 of covid related mortality
deaths in the uk this is not an accident
that that's how we got that's how jcvi
got
to the phase one priority listing
yeah and uh mesa just on your question
about you know how come the
the uk is uh seeming to get the the
vaccine
uh soon early uh perhaps ahead of of
many other countries i think that's
that's really
down to the to the vaccine task force uh
uh more than anything else and
the way they they've gone out to uh to
organize that
but you know what i would say about this
uh all these
all seven of the ones that the uk is
backing that these belong
these are global efforts you've got
scientists around the world coming
together
uh to make this possible and it's a
truly it's a truly international thing
and very very uh moving to to see it on
uh brexit and uh
and where we are with the negotiations
well uh
you know we we're working we remain uh
absolutely committed to trying to
to get a deal if we if we can i think
our friends
uh know the uh what the uk
uh bottom line is and what people voted
for in
uh on june 23rd 2016. they voted to take
back control it's about
uh it's about making sure that the uk is
able to
uh to run its own uh
laws its own fisheries and uh and so on
and that's that's
fundamentally what it's what it's all
about that's what we're that's what
we're all working for um let's go to
hugo guy of the eye thank you uh prime
minister
when you first announced the new tiering
system that's come into effect today uh
you
suggested that it was likely to stay in
place until the end of march
given the good news on vaccines recently
is there a chance that that day could
change and that the
uh current covered restrictions could be
ended early
and professor von van tam can i say can
i ask there's
there's been a lot of attention on the
precise details
of the covid rules recently but perhaps
less attention
on uh the broader principles of
how people can protect themselves
against covid and how kovitz transmitted
are you confident that the public knows
enough about
the risks of covert transmission
particularly for example issues around
ventilation which it now seems maybe
more important than
than other factors that were stressed
early in the pandemic
yeah well you go on your first question
which a lot of
uh colleagues have asked uh in one way
or the other what difference does this
make to the
to the tiering well first thing to say
is for now
it makes absolutely no difference
absolutely
we've got to focus on uh keeping the
virus under control
getting it done uh tough tearing mass
community testing
as i've described but clearly uh as we
go on in the next
uh weeks and and months and hopefully
we're able to use
testing and the vaccine to to drive it
down
wall i suppose there will come a moment
when the
as the graph of people fed up with
graphs but if you imagine a
a graph of uh immunized uh
vaccinated inoculated people going up uh
one way then uh there will come a moment
when we're able obviously
uh to start to relax the uh the
non-pharmaceutical
interventions the uh all the things that
that
uh drive us you know that are so
difficult uh we'll be able
steadily uh we hope uh to take those off
just as as community testing allows what
we hope will allow areas to come down
the
uh the tiering scales but we're not
there yet uh hugo and i've got to stress
that you know
this is theoretical we've got to wait
and see how fast we can
uh vaccinate people uh it's weeks months
of work to to go before we're in that
we're in that situation
alas but you know thank goodness uh we
now have
a vaccine to work with so
thank you hugo on the point about
ventilation i think you make a very good
point indeed
and it's not just because i have some
far eastern origins i'm a great admirer
of um the japanese system of looking for
risk
for transmission of kovid the three c's
to which i had myself d and v
uh the first seek look for closed spaces
often ones with low ventilation
they are risk areas the second c
look for situations where there's going
to be crowding or where you can't avoid
crowding
the third c look for situations where
close contact particularly indoors is
likely to happen
and then finally on top of all that
think about how long you're going to be
in those situations
d duration and then finally
on top of that think v volume how loud
and noisy is it going to be
with people shouting with raised voices
singing etc
um in those kind of closed low
ventilation spaces
these are all recipes for transmission i
hope that helps
thanks very much uh let's go to harry
cole lastly how cold of the sun
thank you prime minister uh question for
professor van tam i know you can't give
us a magical number of
how many people will need to be
vaccinated before we can begin to
lift some measures but can you envisage
your world perhaps
in the winter a new normal where masks
and hand sanitizers just become
part of everyday life and prime minister
um i don't think i heard you give a
direct answer to mace's question there
is this a brexit bonus
have we uh have we beaten the world to
this because we're free from brussels
um and are you concerned that 70
of your mps were unable to back you last
night
and aren't you staring at a defeat in
february or what are you going to do to
win over
your own party on your tier system given
there an open mutiny
um well jv do you wanna know who
john can you go first yeah thank you
thank you prime minister
so um harry to your question um
i'll answer it in kind of three chunks
if i may
number one i don't think we're going to
eradicate
coronavirus ever i think it's going to
be
with humankind forever um
secondly i think we may
get to a point where coronavirus becomes
a
seasonal problem i don't want to draw
too many parallels with flu
but possibly that is the kind of way we
would learn to live with it
and the third point is do i think there
will come a
big moment where we kind of you know
have a massive party and throw on masks
and hand sanitizer
and say that's it it's behind us like
the end of the war
no i don't i think those kind of habits
that we've learned from
that clearly stop the spread of other
respiratory viruses
such as flu will perhaps persist for
many years
and that that may be a good thing if
they do
um yeah so maybe a good thing on the
other hand we may want to
get back to life as pretty much as close
to normal but you know
i mean i i i anyway uh i hope i have
high hopes that the
uh that uh eventually the vaccine will
make a a very very significant
difference the way we
uh we live our we live our lives uh but
um
harry on your on your your point about
you know why
why
on vaccines again i'm going to uh
exercise her self denying all of my
fabled uh
diplomacy and attacked and just say i
think that this is something that
uh you know has been we've been working
on uh
the nhs has been working on a long time
uh the
uh the vaccine task force many people
have been working on this uh very hard
for a long time i pay tribute to
to all of them and as for um you know
what might happen in uh in future uh
decisions of the house of commons
on um where we should go in the in the
tears i totally understand people's
frustrations uh with the the tiering
system i understand people
uh who feel uh frustrated because they
feel they're in the wrong tier
uh they've been attracted into uh
too higher tier by proximity uh to some
uh other
neighborhood that uh has higher
incidence of infection i i know how
people feel about it it's incredibly
frustrating uh what we are going to do
and i said this
many times today and and yesterday we're
going to make sure that we
are as as local and as an as uh you know
sensitive as we can possibly be uh to
local
uh achievement and local incidents of
the
of the disease but don't forget the the
thing i keep saying is that you know
there is this opportunity with mass
community testing for people to acquire
agency in this and to get a test
squeeze the disease uh kick curve it out
even before
uh the vaccine comes so so harry i'd
like to come back because
i do like to be um challenged when i
have perhaps not made myself clear and
the prime minister has picked me up on
this occasion and it's quite all right
i don't know but it's quite all right
because it gives me a chance to
clarify what i mean here i do not
think the government will continue to
have to recommend
social distancing masks and
hand sanitizer forever and a day i hope
we will get back to a much more normal
world
but the point i was trying to make was
do i think
possibly some of those personal habits
for some people will persist
longer and perhaps become enduring for
some people
yes i think that's possible as a as in
as in the furries yes yeah no who knows
who knows
um thank you very much everybody that's
the that concludes the
session for the league thanks harry